Anne: Well, thanks to all of you for coming
to today's authors of Google talk.
We have Harold Jaffe with us today.
And, I wanted to start out the introduction
with
"find a seam... plant a mine... slip away."
Where minds are "imaginative interrogative
constructions in the brethren sense."
This is what Hal Jaffe advocates in the lead
essay for the American Book Review entitled
"Guerilla Writing".
He was thereafter known as the guerilla writer.
Jaffe is the author of numerous docufiction
collections, novels and essays,
which have been translated into German, Japanese,
Spanish, Italian, French, Polish, Czech and
Farsi.
In 2004 the journal of experimental fiction
devoted an issue to ger -- Jaffe's writing
entitled
"The Literary Terrorism of Harold Jaffe"
Wish I could redo that.
He has won many awards including a California
arts council grant in fiction, national endowment
awards in fiction,
several pushcart prizes and 2 Fulbright grants.
Harold Jaffe is a professor of literature
and creative writing at San Francisco State
--
No, I knew I was gonna do that.
At San Diego State, sorry we're in San Francisco.
San Diego State University, and editor and
chief of the literary cultural journal of
fiction international.
And he's here today to talk about his new
book, "Anti-Twitter".
Please welcome.
[applause]
[book clicks against podium]
Harold: "Researchers ask people with high
and low self esteem to repeat, I am a loveable
person.
They then measured participant's feelings
about themselves.
In the low self esteem group, those who repeated
the feel good mantra felt worse afterwards.
However when people with high self esteem
repeated the mantra, they felt better.
Though only slightly."
And "Hello, my name is Slavoj Zizek.
I'm a Lacanian Marxist, a thinker of the highest
order.
But, you know I aspire to be a rock star,
and that's the reason I'm dressed you know
the way I am."
No, actually, I'm Harold Jaffe, as Anne was
kind enough to indicate.
And I'm going to read to you from "Anti-Twitter."
These are all very short.
They're exactly 50 words, and so while I'm
reading, I'll see whether you're slipping
or not.
And then if you are, we can move to questions.
"Walter Benjamin inhabited that place at which
weakness and genius coincide.
Nor did Walter Benjamin kill himself with
an overdose of morphine,
as was widely reported.
He shot morphine into his left thigh because
he never found anything else he liked to inject
into his left thigh nearly as much."
Harold: "Memory, he remembered his name, nothing
more.
After undergoing eye surgery as an adolescent,
he lost the ability to form memories.
For the next 58 years, each time he met a
friend,
each time he ate a meal,
each time he walked the streets, it was the
first time."
"A woman mauled by a kangaroo refused comment
on the bizarre attack.
Kristine V. was assaulted by a boxing kangaroo
outside her upscale condominium yesterday
afternoon,
and taken to hospital.
After being released, she brushed aside the
incident.
Fact, boxing kangaroos have been venturing
ever closer to upscale condominiums."
"Shuffle, they've seized your shoelaces.
You're in a padded cell.
Cement floor, grey padded walls, no window,
no way to hang yourself without shoelaces.
Not much to do but shuffle from the cot to
the steel grey wall and back again.
Remember not to lift your feet in their laceless
shoes."
"Transgender toilet.
A fracas erupted in the Italian parliament's
ladies toilet between MP's Gardini Santa Ride
and Luxuria transgender communist. Gardini
former showgirl expressed outrage after inadvertently
meeting Luxuria, former sex worker in a toilet.
The incident has provoked a heated debate
about which toilet the transgender MP should
properly use."
Harold: "The new U.S. strategy eight bloody
years into Afghanistan is perception.
The current perception is that the campaign
is wildly adrift.
Afghans must perceive that Americans are defeating
the insurgency.
Afghans must perceive their irrecoverable
loss should they choose insurgency over democracy.
That's the idea.
Implementing it won't be easy."
Harold: Reading Nietzsche, I hear a bird in
trouble.
A house finch with a tumor on its head.
I capture it and put it in a cage with water,
feed.
Nietzsche argued vigorously against empathy
then weeping embraced the cart-horse that
had been whipped.
Madness embraced him the following year."
"Vincent Van Gogh under the supervision of
Dr.Gachet shoots himself but misses a vital
organ.
He struggles to his cot and lies there facing
the wall.
When his devoted brother Theo comes, Vincent
refuses to turn from the wall.
He dies that way two days later, facing the
wall."
"Lady Day is ambulanced to metropolitan hospital
in New York with liver and heart disease May
31st 1959.
Arrested at the hospital for heroin possession,
remains under police guard at the hospital
until she dies from cirrhosis of the liver
July 17th 1959.
44 years old, nobody knew who she was."
"An unaccounted victim of the United States
torture policy,
Is a young army corporal from New Jersey.
Name withheld.
She witnessed the violent interrogation of
Iraqi prisoners and was deeply troubled.
Six weeks after her appeal for reassignment
was denied, she shot herself dead with her
government issue semi-automatic."
"War Mother
The reason I'm standing in the rain handing
out 'Stop the War' flyers is my son Chamillo.
He joined up to learn a trade seventeen years
old.
I gave permission because where we live was
just drugs and gangs.
Better the Marines than jail.
Now I'm thinking jail would have been better."
These are not just any spaces, you know as
I'm looking for the text to read, these are
charred spaces.
You know, I think of it in the Buddhist sense.
You know, like the space between notes and
Beethoven's late quartets for example.
That's how I like to think of them.
"19 Toucans.
Gazing through the small cracked window of
her room at dusk, she sees 19 toucans flying
low, languidly in single file from west to
east.
It was said there were alligators in the mangroves.
Naked, she lies on her back in a mangrove
swamp in the jungle denseness."
"Chet Baker
After a heroin deal turned bloody, the baby-faced
bad boy is transformed into mister down and
out.
The interesting thing is Chet doesn't seem
to care.
Not being pretty, face busted up, age 27.
Shoot the right grade of shit and you just
don't give a shit."
"Machine Sex.
No hokey come ons.
No pheromone aftershave.
No premature ejack.
No sexual politics.
No big dick narcissism.
No faked foreplay.
No insincere dirty talk.
No I've shot my bolts, sorry about that.
Machines provide exactly what you need.
And if apres sex you want a cigarette, you
don't have to share."
Well here's something finally about technology.
I've been describing a wide art, you know,
but here's something for technology.
"Dead wired
Online social networks are crucial to our
lives and increasingly crucial when we die.
An industry has emerged to deal with online
contacts after death.
Through a site called deathswitch, humans
post posthumous e-mails announcements on online
social networks.
And send text messages.
Current cost, $16.00 per month."
"About Opium.
Jean Cocteau himself addicted suggested that
official chemistry modify opium's toxicity
while salvaging the euphoria.
Which would mean ungoverned pleasure committed
by the ungovernable.
Not just in the realm of culture as with dada
for example,
but spiriting its bliss into the most intimate
orifices of globalism."
"A man pretending to be dying of cancer was
sentenced to prison.
The former Pontiac salesman claimed to have
kidney, lung and prostate cancer.
He shaved his head and dropped red dye in
the toilet to simulate blood in his urine.
He faked seizures, slamming his head into
walls."
"Kung Fu TV legend David Carradine was found
hanging naked inside a wardrobe in his Bangkok
luxury hotel.
A chord was attached to his neck, and a second
chord to his genitals.
There was no suicide note.
The possibility of a sex game gone wrong could
not be ruled out."
"Researchers have begun to unravel the information
and social content embedded in the hyena's
uncanny laugh.
Younger hyenas have high-pitched giggles.
And dominant females of the strongly hierarchical
clans have a narrower range of sounds.
It has been hypothesized that the laughing
is not a sign of good humor."
I'm going to hasten toward the end a little
bit here.
"Blame it on Chavez.
The Easter dish of choice in Venezuela is
the capybara.
An oversized rodent, cousin to the guinea
pig though river based like a beaver.
Venezuelans regard the creature as more fish
than meat.
A useful deception during lent when it replaces
red meat in this predominately Roman Catholic
country."
"Young Fulbrighter, I'd landed in Islamabad
international airport when I heard John Lenon
singing 'Imagine' for the first time.
I've heard it innumerable times sense, but
today 5-17-09 in the small market near my
Paris flat, I hear it while shopping and am
moved.
Can it be 38 years?"
"Butoh, B-U-T-O-H
The Japanese spirit dance meanders in twists
and turns between living and dead.
Dead is another version of irrational.
Whenever I gaze around me, I want to plunge
into the irrational.
Whenever I look upward, face downward or stare
in front of me, I want to plunge in the irrational."
"Last Words, Death Row.
Well Mums, that's how it played out.
Love life, live long.
Dealin' with reality ain't always what you
want it to be.
Tell my kids I love 'em.
God is real.
He fixin' to find out some deep things that
are real.
Take care of yourselves.
Last Words, Death Row.
Been hangin' round this popsicle stand way
too long.
Before I go, I wanna say something to all
ya'll.
Bury me deep, lay two speakers at my feet,
put headphones on my skull and rock 'n' roll
me when I'm dead.
Shit eaters, I'll see you in hell."
Thank you.
Harold: You know, I find a text.
I don't always alter the figure of the text,
but I alter the ground.
I put it in some other place.
I sometimes change the spaces.
And the original text is not art.
But the one in the other context is art.
Why is it art?
Because I proposed that it be art.
It's a conceptual notion, right?
You know, I think of the Thai artist Tiravanija.
He was involved in a kind of installation
process where he would bicycle around the
New York area and find deserted Gaps or devastated
Rite Aids.
Or these cavernous kinds of ex-large stores.
And he would furnish them with stoves and
refrigerators and chairs and long tables and
comfort food.
And he would invite the homeless to eat.
And they would be fed, he himself would be
serving the food.
And they would be fed for 23 days.
Homeless people would feed homeless people
for 23 days.
Then he would give away the appliances and
move on.
Find another place and do the same thing for
23 days.
Twenty-three was William Burroughs favorite
number, if you remember that.
And, he himself didn't propose that what he
was doing was art, but other people did.
There was no residue.
There was no except you know the food that
the people ate.
There was no -- there was nothing palpable
about what it was that could be called art.
And yet he called it art.
And arguably it is a kind of art, conceptually.
Not so much the aesthetic object, but what
it does to the mind.
I mean how one thinks about it afterwards.
That's something of what I'm doing by displacing
these file texts.
Which profess to be information.
But we know that actually they're mostly disinformation,
deception, distraction and ideology.
And by defamiliarizing them, one can see them
differently, more clearly.
Sometimes I alter them fairly decisively.
Other times I do very little to them.
It's also the proximity of where they are
and the texts that are around them that matter.
You know, as I was mentioning to Galen, back
when we were walking here.
You know our milieu has changed.
It's very difficult for us to get back to
fundamental things.
You know, we don't hear the mockingbird.
You know wilderness is being real estated
and so on.
Our milieu now is what professes to be information.
That's the data we work with.
That's the kind of material that we can do
some interesting art with.
It's not so much the idea of drafting something,
it's more the idea of discovering something.
You know, one doesn't have to be a good draftsman
or draftswoman to be a good visual artist
these days.
Discovering, defamiliarizing, being alert
in that way can cover you I think interestingly.
What is my disposition to all of this?
Well, what do you think?
Do, do, do you infer some disposition, some
attitude that I have to this,
or is it just pretty much hugger mugger here?
Well you know, my attitude is to interrogate,
you know, clearly.
And to tease out whatever subtexts are there.
Sometimes you don't have to do much more than
simply displace it.
I mean, there are important and obvious precedents
to this.
Probably the most famous one is Duchamp finding
the urinal.
It wasn't in Paris, but it was some street
in France.
And then writing "R.Mutt" on it and exhibiting
it.
Didn't do anything to the figure at all except
maybe cleaned it up a little bit.
Added R.Mutt, but just changed the ground.
And there we had a found object that became
art.
Became a certain kind of art.
And that started a way of thinking, at least
in the West that's been influential.
Do you want me to read a few more things to
you?
I didn't read all the incendiary ones.
>> I have a--
Harold: Yeah, please
>>Related to what we were talking about, concerning
artists.
This stuff comes from our morning page.
On claiming that there is [inaudible] at least
on the more serious one to address the social
issues of the day.
Is there any need in art or artists?
Harold: Yeah, well it's an important and inevitable
question that.
And I'm easy to answer.
You know I think of the writer Claribel Alegria
who is Nicaraguan.
And she was writing particularly during the
United States invasion of Nicaragua, and Iran-contra.
And where they would use drug money to furnish
the contras.
And she was asked about this imperative.
And she said, yes, she feels that the artists
must address this, must bracket his or her
concerns and address this.
And, the interviewer in fact, I was the interviewer
asked her, what would she do if she met an
artist who wasn't addressing the war and the
U.S. colonialism in Nicaragua?
And she said I'd refuse to shake his hand.
Now you might ask, what is it that permits
the writer or the artist to have a special
access or particular ability to articulate
these difficulties and to address social questions.
And to be socially activist.
What would you say about that?
I mean, is there anything that -- and honestly
people don't necessarily say all lawyers,
you know should address the social issues
of the day.
They might say that it would be good if doctors
you know joined Médecins Sans Frontières,
right?
But with writers and artists, one does hear
this.
Why though?
What is it about let's say writers that give
them any kind of special access into this?
So do you have any feelings about that?
>>Personally, well I don't think there should
be expressional art in any form to the degree
that
you know if it is a social issue is what motivates
you or that spurs you on, then that's great.
But if you are an artist, and that's not your
emphasis, I don't think there's anything wrong
with that.
Cuz art is just free expression.
Harold: Yeah, good point.
But is the free expression really free or
is it secretly complicitis?
I mean, take an exaggerated situation like
the Third Reich.
You know, a lot of artists left Germany when
this was going on.
But some didn't.
Some Aryan artists continued to produce.
And they weren't writing about the war or
doing images about the war.
They were writing about the homeland and the
country,
and the kinds of mythologies that have always
been you know evident in Germany.
Now, were they simply expressing themselves,
or by turning their back on what was going
on, were they being complicitis?
>> Complicitis, but I look at it more as perhaps
survival.
In a sense that you know, those artist might
have agreed with the Third Reich ideology.
But then again they decided to stay, it might
have been just a matter of survival.
Of not being able to have the courage to speak
truth to the powers.
Harold: Yeah, sure, no I think that is well
put.
>>The thing is that I'm trying to take this
position where I'm not judging.
But after the same time as a human being I
you know I do judge.
That particular ideology is totally offensive
to me, and I would think that anybody would
come against it.
But life has so many shades of grey.
And you know, people are put in so many difficult
situations, it's just really hard to say if
they were being complicit or supporting that
ideology.
Or in a sense, just trying to survive.
Not having the courage to speak out.
Harold: Yeah, no, understood.
I think what at least theoretically gives
an artist a particular access that people
in other profession might not so readily have
is that the artist cultivates dream space
and cultivates rumination.
And spends time thinking in ways that aren't
permitted to let's say people who work from
8 to 6.
And the insights that come from this kind
of contemplation are different and often useful
to you know, to articulating.
Also artists, if they have any kind of reputation,
have easy access to media.
You know that other people don't have.
Now take the situation of AIDS.
When AIDS was happening, you know you're a
young woman, and so you were very young then
if you were even born.
The kind of hate that was let lose was quite
extraordinary, even for a country like this.
The hate that was addressed, especially to
gay men then, that's one act up and grand
fury came together,
And gay people, but not exclusively gay people
bracketed what they were doing, and they decided
to try to expropriate the expropriator.
And use the very weapons, you know the propaganda
against the people and institutions who were
demonizing people with AIDS.
And that's when the battle turned.
And I think even though an entire generation
was lost, I do believe it would have been
a lot worse if act up and grand fury didn't
poster St. Patrick's cathedral where the then
cardinal was making --
was about to give some talk demonizing AIDS,
people with AIDS and so on.
I think it would have been a lot worse than
it actually was.
So there art intervention actually was very
useful.
Sometimes it can't be measured in that way.
And even when it can't be measured, you know,
I think there's a valid argument for it.
But you know, having said this, I do agree
with you.
That I don't know that the imperative actually
applies to everyone.
There are some people who are incapable you
know as artists.
>>I was gonna say.
They are wired to personally.
Harold: Yeah.
>> You know, I do believe artists have that
obligation to address this issue.
In fact I was thinking my daughter is a theatre
major at University San Francisco.
And part of that major is theatre as social
justice.
And that part is combined.
Harold: Yeah
>> And as she comes home, you know in her
youthful vigor, she talks about her art and
how it influences and how she really wants
to change things.
And that is a perfect complement.
But at the same time, I think about some artist
who just wants to get on television and be
on "American Idol" and do something like that.
They're an artist, but I don't think they're
pushing any kind of social agenda.
Harold: No I'm happy to hear that.
But you know, as far as changing, effecting
change.
One can't ever expect the response to be commensurate
with the effort.
I think at a time like now, it's a question
of bearing witness.
Of you know, nobody knows what's gonna happen
to the works we do.
Whether they'll be absolutely in the hands
of managers, you know corporate managers.
Or whether they'll be somehow alive on the
net.
Assuming that the net has some degree of freedom,
you know 25 years or 30 years from now.
But the notion of bearing witness is a very
important one, especially in a time like now
because change has been so accelerated.
Just think, the last 15 years how people think,
particularly in technology of course, has
affected the way the world is viewed.
Language, you know, has changed radically,
very rapidly because of the very short hand
ways.
We don't look at events directly anymore,
not that we're always easily able to,
we look at them in a mediated way through
a screen or through a small screen.
But what's going on is instead of looking
there, there's violence there, we look here
and we see the mediated form of the violence
which of course is gonna have some lies and
some you know some changes that are.
So the idea of being an artist who bears witness,
I don't think that's negligible.
But again, you're right, there are people
who aren't wired to do that.
There aren't artists, there are some artists
And even if they live in a toxic, you know,
environment such as the Third Reich.
Perhaps one can argue that you know, they're
still doing the best they can.
I think that's possible.
>> Here's another question.
It's sort of falls under the same umbrella.
How does the influence that corporate or government
sponsors pull on the current artist.
Oh, I'm sorry, did I?
Harold: No, I know what you mean.
If you're doing an exhibit which is virulently
interrogative of what government and corporations
are doing and it's being shown at the museum
of modern art in New York, and it's sponsored
by Mobil, right?
And Mobil does sponsor it.
What does that mean?
I mean are you being complicit?
I mean when you see something on the wall
in the museum sponsored by Mobil, you don't
look at it in the same way as you might if
you saw it in some sort of handout.
The same thing applies to writers arguably
who publish a book with Simon and Schuster.
You know which professes to be you know interrogative.
Simon and Schuster wouldn't do it unless they
misread it, which is very likely.
And is the fact that it has that imprint immediately
compromised?
It's a hard question.
I mean the fact is you know we're living at
a very imperfect time.
And there are all kinds of quibbles and small
sacrifices that one makes.
If you see Guernica in the museum of modern
art or some other place, do you think about
the small Spanish town that's being bombed
by the fascists?
Or do you just see another exquisite experiment
by Picasso there.
That's part of the question, yeah.
>> Well, I think if I understand things properly,
what's going on is really a question of whether
an omission can be an act.
So if you have a duty to do something and
when omitting is safe, then an artist has
a duty to be socially active.
Whether failing to perform that duty is you
know really something that you know can be
you know display worthy.
And what I find interesting is that in European
countries, omission is generally considered
to be at least in law something culpable.
So if you see someone drowning, and you could
save them by throwing them a rope and you
don't, that actually can be prosecuted.
But in America, no state can be prosecuted.
Harold: Yeah, that's an interesting point.
Very subtle.
Yeah, you know, there isn't any ongoing tradition
of socially activist art in the United States.
I mean there've been moments.
There were the Transit Analysts who were against
the slave trade.
There were the people associated with IWW.
There were the 30's communists, most of whom
changed when Stalin came to power.
There certainly, you know in the 60's, for
that blip of a period from 1966 let's say
to 1972, there were young people who at least
in France came close to overthrowing the country.
But there were as you know, in '68, there
were protests and very powerful ones across
the world in places you wouldn't expect.
But, and including America.
But generally speaking, if you compare the
United States with France.
If you compare it even with England.
If you compare it with Germany.
There hasn't been any ongoing vital ongoing
social activist response in art.
Just spots.
But. and that itself is an interesting question.
Why that should be?
And I think the response to that is complex.
It has to do with a number of factors that
govern, you know, this country and--
--and sustain the way this country functions.
>> I mean socially it has to tie in the sort
of American mythology about personal freedom.
Harold: Yeah.
>> So, here's the question.
Why do recurring folks on the [inaudible ]list
The outrage of the current society, and the
responsibility of the artists in these times
seem to both be clear things.
Poverty is a timeless issue.
How does it fit into your general argument?
Harold: How does the notion of poverty fit
into these?
Well, you know I think, you know I read last
words from people on death row.
I think one of the important points is to
see these people from the subject position.
And I've dealt with this in different ways,
extreme ways where I've talked about serial
killers and so on.
And It's very easy to demonize people.
And also I've written about art brut people
who are accounted, I use that verb deliberately
who are accounted mad.
And, but do some very unusual art.
Art that's valued, but sometimes marginalized.
I try to see them from the subject position.
That is to imagine them talking or even to
find places where they've articulated
sentences or in certain instances art, visual
art.
I think seeing them from the subject position
and hearing them is important.
Whether it's a political prisoner.
Whether it's a very very poor person who's
handing out some homeless leaflet.
I think insofar as possible, and it's not
always easily possible as you know to hear
them from the subject position.
Instead of having them objectified, and hearing
the same kinds of platitudes of moralistic
platitudes about them.
I think that's an important first step.
And when you hear them, you know what I did
is I went back to the records of Texas prisoners
who were executed.
And I actually got to the final statements,
which again I treated.
I changed in certain ways.
They were extraordinarily articulate and very
powerful and very poetic.
None of that's heard.
You know, they're just, you know most of them
as you would expect were Mexican or African
American or American Indian.
And none of that was heard.
They were allowed to have these last words
the way they were allowed to have a last meal,
but all of its forgotten.
But I didn't want it to be forgotten, so I
rescued it.
And I put it in a different context.
Part of what I read was from that.
But I've a large thing called Death in Texas.
A large text where I actually, I have about
30 prisoners who are about to be executed
talk.
And I inserted some unusual things in it that
didn't belong there.
I actually took a 19th century person from
a German institution for the mental incapacitated,
and I inserted that.
Made some changes into the prisoners, the
death row prisoners.
Nobody was able to distinguish that.
Nobody said a word about that, it was published
in a number of places.
Madam, that would be the first step I think.
To allow them to articulate from the subject
position.
You know without interfering.
I think that itself is not a small first step.
Because when you hear, when you allow yourself
to hear, you know or see what people who are
otherwise severely marginalized are doing
then even the coldest least feeling, least
compassionate people are not likely, but liable
to be moved.
And that's not unimportant I think.
Yeah?
>> As mass communication sort of moves seemingly
to increasing form of illiteracy [inaudible]
social [inaudible]
Are examples [Inaudible] texts becoming harder
to find?
Harold: Well they're becoming very different.
Everything is very abbreviated.
Which makes it easier for me because I'm deliberately
working in very short units.
I chose 50 words rather than the number of
characters of twitter because that didn't
allow me enough access.
But by choosing 50 words, it forced me into
closing and opening of certain spaces.
Yeah, in a traditional sense certainly, the
discourse has changed.
It's much more dumbed down than it was.
And the references are much more restricted.
You never find any high cultural references
or rarely there.
I mean if you read the American newspapers,
or American you know whether they are online
or off.
So it's much more parochial, you know than
it was.
The advantage of it is that it's brief.
Because newspapers you know are ape computers
now, so everything looks like U.S. World,
U.S. News today.
You know, everything looks like that now.
And so it's easier to plunder, you know.
It's easier to bushwack these texts because
of their abbreviation.
But yeah, they don't point in as many directions
as you'd like them to.
On the other hand, if they were cultivated,
and pointed in those other directions, they
might not interest you know us plunderers,
you know in the same way.
Because they would be viable, you know, insofar
as you know that kind of news can be viable.
That's a subtle question, it's a good question.
>> Here's another question, and it goes to
your book.
What inspired you to use the twitter format?
And do you use twitter at all?
Harold: Do I, the last part was am I on twitter
myself?
I have an account there, I don't I haven't
followed it up because I have,
between my writing and fiction international,
I'm on so many different social network sites
sometimes that I'm not doing them myself.
But the assistance on the Journal Fiction
International are.
I use it, I use it in an emblematic way.
As representing the new communication in "Anti-Twitter"
I mean I could have said anti facebook.
Of course, I wanted to use twitter because
of the abbreviation.
The extreme abbreviation.
And I think it's like text messaging.
That's what's been changing you know, the
language.
Now if you asked me what I think about the
language being changed, I have mixed feelings.
I like some of the innovations that lets say
rap singers and sports people have used where
they play around with their name.
T-Mac for Tracy McGrady and so on, I think
that's amusing and I like that.
But the language otherwise is changing in
ways that are you know funny and theatrical,
but I think finally leaving us less leverage
to be expressive than we'd like to be.
You know, I like listening to it, but it's
-- the leverage is getting narrower and narrower.
And I think that's a problem.
And it's moving so fast.
That's the reason I dealt with it.
Because the last 15 years have moved much
more, much faster than the previous 15 years.
And it's that speed, and often speed without
direction that I wanted to address.
>> [Inaudible]
>> In "Suicides", was the order of the stories
within intended to prepare the readers to
sympathize with Hamas suicide bombers?
If I would have read it [inaudible]
A lot of people would have been outraged.
[inaudible]
Instead I found myself related to the acts
of Hamas, the acts of the character in the
previous stories.
Not judging any of them were bad, rational
or irrational, but simply as acts that are
somehow prick the conscience.
Harold: That's a very subtle question.
I've never been asked that question before.
And the answer is yes, you're right.
What I did in this text called "Suicides",
I wrote about the suicides of Mishima, Simone
Wilde, Johnny Ace who was an early rhythm
and blues singer.
And there was somebody else/
And the last one was a Hamas suicide bomber,
where I just detailed something.
And yeah, I was trying to finesse the reader
into reading that fairly and in a broader
context, that's right I was.
That's a very good perception.
>> There are a couple twists.
Harold: Yeah, keep going if you like, they're
good questions.
>> OK, five points, five point restraints.
"Brilliant, silence has developed solely with
a view to the pursuit that limits performances
to the detriment of any effort to discover
a coherent truth useful to humanity."
Yet doesn't quantum physics seek universal
truth?
Harold: Yeah, I think Quantum Physics does.
But one of the points that Virilio makes is
that increasingly science is allied to technology.
That one -- I mean people talk about pure
science, but now it's largely become, not
entirely, but largely become techno science.
And so when scientists are working and need
money, they get money from corporations.
And they get money from the government.
They get that money, they're compelled, you
know -- it's like judging some drug that the
F.D.A. is putting on the market.
They're compelled to respond in a particular
way.
To leave certain things out you know as Nicholas
was saying.
To omit certain kinds of things.
Yeah, I think in principle you're right.
You know certainly Quantum Mechanics and other
aspects of post Einsteinian and even in philosophy,
let's say post Vichtenstein kind of thinking.
I think that's very useful insofar as it could
be understood.
You know, and even if it's not understood,
it's useful in some way.
But I think there's much less of that.
Consider, you know, a scientist who's teaching
can't make the same kind of living as he or
she did previously unless the person's getting
grants.
And who's giving these grants, I mean it's
that kind of thing.
Historians, the same way.
I mean, if you're Howard Zinn, or Chomsky,
you could write pretty much what you want.
But even Chomsky has dealt with lots of hate.
I was in San Francisco a number of years ago.
When I did a book with City Lights,
and he was giving a talk at Berkeley.
And there was a letter from Berkeley professors,
many of them Jewish, a number of them previously
progressive who were denouncing him.
They were calling him, they were accusing
him of Jewish self-hatred,
of being pro-palestinian,
of not recognizing the power of the holocaust.
I mean all of these things.
And so it's very difficult to take an independent
stance without having the funds to make sure
that it's published in such a way that people
can read it.
Hence, you look for money, and once you look
for money, compromises ensue.
>>[inaudible]
>>Thank you very much for coming.
Harold: Thank You.